it's time now for the uplift at 8 where  we share stories that will bring some  joy to your day and here it is a  massachusetts toddler getting national  attention for her adorable antics on  tick tock take a look  i'm wearing a strawberry shirt  and  so that's three-year-old june mcgann  showing off her little strawberry outfit  her funny video and her love of crocs  have gotten more than two million views  on tick tock jun's parents were worried  that she would be shy since she was born  right before the pandemic but as you can  see clearly that is not the case the  couple told us the toddler is very  articulate and always says exactly  what's on her mind i love the little  outfit and jun's on national tv  little june  junior you know people people always  think their kids are going to be  affected by the environment but i say as  a parent of four they are born a  particular way and they are just that  way i love you june yeah